Just pretend this is me and instead of Vosch's community, I say
DG. Vos literally does that. Destiny literally does that constantly.
I I will never match the caricature or the the similacer that
he's created to represent who I am. I will never align with that
because that is an object, a caricature created with no reference
to anything I've ever said or done. That's fine, but I don't
know that. Does that make any difference? What do you have to
do, Admiral? Nobody. I want you to tell me. Hassan is evil, so
I just have no charity for him. You tell me why he's evil and
then tell me what decisions you make about him or what you do
about him because he's evil. I'd love to hear that. Said he loved
Hitler. It's first amendment protected speech in this country
that there shall not be viewpoint discrimination. I don't care
if Assan said America deserved 911 20 times. It's called being
principled in favor of free speech for American citizens cuz
it's going to happen to you, too.
Okay,
that's uh I don't know about that. Couldn't even hear what he
said. I don't even know what he said. Surprised they put up gay
stuff on Iranian TV. True. This is after they gave it to me.
Okay, I don't think I need to hear too much more of Hassan. I'm
going to watch the Pisco victory lap stream and then we'll see
if I can find the uh the Pisco stuff on the LA riots as well.
Okay,
one second. One second. One second. I also might have Meowi's
coming back for more of the um Pirate Software stuff in a little
bit. So, we'll see. Just trying to lock that down as well. Okay,
Pisco stream
coming in hot. Let's check it out. Hassan Victory Lab streamed
one day ago. Post lip and learn victory
lap stream of mine. I hope that you guys are all on the edge
of your seats because once again I am vindicated on my positions
on things in the universe and I am so looking forward to all
of the copers in the chat and hopefully in VC tonight
to argue why this doesn't show anything
to argue why oh it's still nothing still a liar. all that. Well,
Hunter, I think you're arguing that they have the authority to
do it. And it's like I don't think I'd argue against you they
have the authority to do it. It's whether it's good or bad, right?
Like obviously when a when a when a government organization has
for any reason we determine we will actually just ban you. Yeah,
[__] that. Um but no, complete and total utter vindication.
All haters have been decimated. And so yeah, I'm just like very
curious what the arguments left are. What are the arguments left
that Hassan, for all his faults, for all his problems, for all
of his many
things he said? For what it's worth, I wouldn't be surprised
if knowingly providing a platform to a member of a designated
terrorist organization toes the line of the cannot satisfy CBP
of your own of your low-risk status. Well, it would also be it.
Why would it be that and not the terrorism support statute or
uh the outlay they have there for that explicitly the terrorism
thing?
Why wouldn't it just be that? Why would it be something else?
The moral things he said, stances he's taken as early as as recently
as like this week on like Gavin Newsome wasn't a victim of viewpoint
discrimination. What are the arguments left?
Seriously. So, we now have confirmation because we've seen the
letter that okay
Global Entry was revoked in sometime in March it looks like about
a couple months or a month after he received it. So, this isn't
a Global Entry interview. Okay. His entry was revoked prior to
his flight. Yes. And so there is no Oh, this was that guy not
advertising himself as a Houthie? Um I mean he was advertising
himself as a Yemeni like Houthy supporter. Absolutely.
Hassan advertised him as a Houthy rebel. Yeah. This is just one
of those routine random stops. The random stops people. Those
people are BTFOed. All the random stops people. Yeah. But they
can I don't think I ever advocated random stops. I said probably
targeted stops, but probably like targeted in terms of here's
like a designated terrorist organization list and we look for
like keywords ne next to your name and with regards to these
like terrorist organizations. I figured he was probably filtered
down to, but it wasn't it wasn't necessarily random. It was just
like, yeah, you kind of been pointed out as like somebody who
might have these problems. So, why are you in the global entry
lane when you don't have the path stop? It might be. Yeah. And
revoke it for a bunch of reasons. This is what this guy wants
you to believe, Ziri. So this is what Ziri wants you to believe
that they granted him his global entry like in what is this?
February. Why don't we get the dates completely correct here?
All right, let's get the dates completely correct. But they granted
it in like February or whenever they granted it. Then they rescended
it a month later and that it was unconnected
to the overarching policy that the Trump administration was engaged
in regarding Hassan's speech and speech in favor of Palestine
and against Israel and speech against
um the Trump administration. You want us to believe that it's
just oh a random a random nonspech related reason that in that
interim period they found out that's what you want us to believe.
And it's also random that when they stopped him out in the uh
in the airport in Chicago that they were questioning him about
that very same thing. So the argument here now has to be it can't
be the Houthy thing, right? That's what Pisco is saying. Can't
be the Houthy thing because the Houthy thing was known before
this. So, they did the background check and they found something,
some new conduct between the two points. Right now, I don't know
if that's 100% correct. Maybe they could be informed of some
old conduct or something, but that's what he's trying to say
is they found some new conduct that's upsetting, that's like
concerning. It has to be something in that period.
We'll see. It's all just random because he brought about the
question in himself. That's what you want us to believe. You
want us to believe it's all random. That is
Completely BTFOed. Can we at least BTFO all of the random
Well, how do we know it was granted? You guys are coping. It
says that the Global Entry program was revoked for him.
Do you ever get something revoked that you don't have? I I just
have a quick question for you. For you guys, do you guys live
in a place where the English language is deployed? I'm just very
curious if you guys live in a place with the English language.
So, can you guys explain to me is this a valid debate topic or
a valid debate argument?
I try to use this and people it's so ineffective.
Like, hey, do you know what English means? Do you know how to
speak English? Do you know how to interpret English? It could
be so clear that something's meant by some words put together
and people just deny that they're related. It's crazy. When you
use the term revoke,
what does that mean to you? Actually, does it mean like deny
as an initial matter? What do you mean by revoke? Actually, this
is not arguing. You see the bad faith in the dodgginess of the
question, right? No one's saying. So, the argument is, was Han's
thing revoked for like a good reason? And Pisco goes, oh, he
makes fun of this guy and the guy goes, oh, is it a right? And
it's like that wasn't the argument. It's whether it's not it
makes sense for the government to revoke it. Like whether or
not that's done in good faith, whether or not that that's done
for good reasons. Like the government has the right to do a whole
bunch of things. It's like whether or not it's right for them
to do that to you. That's like most of the argument, right? At
least with regards to political speech and political speech adjacent
to terrorism. I guess global entry is a right. That's not what
anyone's talking about is stupid. Literal idiots.
We're not talking about whether global entry is a right or not.
entry into the country is a right, just to be clear. But if you
said global entry conditioned on your race, would you would you
ever say something like, "Well, is it a right to have global
entry? Is it a right to have global entry?" That's not what we're
talking about here. That's
exactly
That's what I said. He said it's viewpoint discrimination. Yeah,
that's what I said. Well, and I think political speech, political
affiliation is protected. I think that's a protected class. So,
yeah, I that was my argument. Oh, I don't have to watch Pisco.
I can derive Pisco's arguments from
I don't know logical reasoning. I guess what we're talking about
here is the basis for the revocation. That's what we're talking
about, not whether or not the benefit is a right or not. Jesus
Christ. So, we're talking about specifically the rationale for
the revocation. And I saw someone in the chat say, and I think
it's the same person. Well, there's a bunch of valid reasons.
There's a bunch of valid reasons why it could have been revoked.
So, this is what you have to believe, right? to believe that,
right? I agree. There are valid reasons under which global entry
can be revoked. This is what you legitimately have to believe.
You have to believe that in this short interim of time
that happens to coincide. I think he applied for this right after.
Hold on a second. Wouldn't you want to have some evidence that
viewpoint discrimination was actually why it was removed to make
that assertion? Otherwise, why are you making it? Is that not
true? So, the evidence would be that he wasn't discriminated
against. What has changed since Hsan was granted participation
in that program and what is the likelihood that that has to do
with the the change over to the Trump administration? Right?
I think that's probably the the line Pisc is going to go down
is the big change in terms of government policy
has been Trump taking office and his broad crackdown on anti-Israel
or pro Palestinian speech in general. Right? they're black bagging
people who supported the protests like this, right? That's going
to be where the argument is going to go. He's going to say that
seems like the most likely thing by far. He's going to have some
exclusion criteria for the other likely cases. I don't know what
his exclusion criteria for the Rick Scott thing will be other
than I think it would be wrong to do it for the Rick Scott thing
because the Rick Scott thing was in fact not a threat of violence.
I think it's stupid. But hey, or just writing probs opeds. Exactly.
I don't like this what is the percentage chance based on no evidence
thing. Oh, you can opt out of like reasoning through arguments
like this, but I mean there are going to be lots of cases where
you have to argue things like this and you would want to be able
to make your point without strong evidence, right? If all you
do in your entire life is only operate in in fields where you
have 100% certainty or where you can prove that you're correct
about something, you're going to have a really unfulfilling empty
life. Okay? You will have situations where you have like opaque
opaque visibility into a situation and you have to try to rationalize
why you're going to make a decision. This is a very interesting
and fun exercise to engage in that I love doing. So, shut the
[__] up. Um, I don't actually don't shut the up.
I Apollo's Heights. I'm glad that you're making uh counterpoints.
Okay. I should be more respectful of the people who are willing
to argue with me in the chat. I shouldn't tell them to shut the
up. Okay. Apollo's Heights, I love you. Thank you very much for
engaging. Know what this super chat's saying? You want to believe
this part of a pervasive sneaky policy when they brag about their
Yeah, I know, right? Like this is a part of a pervasive and sneaky
policy when they brag about their Yes. I think it would be probably
that the was the were the crackdowns happening? They happened
really fast. They might have been. Um, yeah, sure. I don't know
exactly what Pisco's argument is going to be because I don't
know what the exclusion criteria are. I do think it could be
the Rick Scott things. Like I think probably my concern is that
like probably if I was going to argue against Pisco, I think
the best argument would be government moves slow. They might
actually just be picking up the Houthy thing. They might actually
just be picking up that he um threatened Tom Cotton, right? They
might actually have no they might be so far behind that they're
picking up on things from like a year ago or a year and a half
ago, right?
That that would be my argument here if I was trying to argue
against Pisco. It is part of like we could be it could be speech
from a year and a half ago that really isn't protected. Posting
a picture of a well-known political assassination weapon in response
to Tom Cotton is not protected political speech. Sorry, it's
not that. Yeah. I mean, are you really trying to I I can't tell
if you're being like cute or if you're being serious that like
you think it's not a any chance we're going to do that later,
Barube. Yeah, we're doing it. You'd have to be a total fool to
take the Trump administration at its worst
to do with his first amendment protected speech. But let's let's
just talk about what you have to believe to believe this is one
of the valid reasons, right? So, everyone agrees there are valid
by valid I mean which to say legal reasons to resent global entry,
right? If they found out that Hassan had lied on his Global Entry
form. Okay, if he committed a crime, okay, global entry, even
if they like find him he's a security threat or something. Okay,
global entry, right? Revoked, right? So, there are all these
good reasons potentially that you could revoke global entry 100%.
Yeah, you absolutely can. All right. I will be honest. I was
looking at chat and not listening to Pisco list the arguments.
I think the Trump administration at its word that it has first
amendment protected speech. But let's let's just talk about what
you have to believe to believe this is one of the valid reasons,
right? Everyone agrees there are valid by valid I mean which
to say legal reasons to present global entry right if they found
out that Hassan had lied on his global entry form. Okay. If he
committed a crime. Okay. Global entry. Even if they like find
him he's a security threat or something. Okay. I missed these
right is bad. So there are all these good reasons potentially
that you could revoke global entry. 100%. Yeah. You absolutely
can. All right. In order to believe that Hassan's
global entry was revoked on one of these good reasons, you have
to believe that in the interim in which he was granted his global
entry, that is to say sometime in February. See, this is this
is probably where I would disagree with Pisco. By the way, if
you're ever arguing with Pisco, this is where you have to disagree
with him. Okay? You have to disagree on one of Pisco's base premises
because if you don't disagree on a base premise, he will mostly,
most of the time, he's making arguments on stream. Uh this is
a good way to make yourself seem really good at debate. You just
build a logic tree where from your premises premises the conclusions
naturally follow, right? From base premises, but you don't make
it very obvious that those base premises followed like your your
conclusion follows from those, right? So you basically set up
some basic yes or no questions like three or four basic yes or
no questions that if somebody says yes or no in the way you want
to each of them, you're automatically correct. And then you figure
out clever ways to argue those that don't make it clear what
your final conclusion is going to be. And then you just argue
those and then you have a bunch of ways to get gotcha people
in between. Right? This is, by the way, most lawyers will do
this. This is how you do like um like of witnesses and stuff.
Pisco is very good at this. But if you don't disagree on like
a base premise he has, if you agree if you say yes to Pisco like
three times in a row, you've lost the debate already, right?
Almost every time you've you've lost the debate because he will
know that he has a like a logic tree that destroys you by the
time you said yes a couple times. I don't know if my stream is
still up. My stream fell up. I'm just going to turn. Not convinced
that a Middle East war could result in a world war, sir. Cuz
I think it's causing my All right. One second. Well, I do think
the US would participate. I I do think it could, but I don't
think it will this time. Okay. What's up, guy? With a mean smirk
in order to believe Oh, hello. that his global entry was revoked
for a valid purpose. You would have to believe that in that like
one-month interim between being granted under the Trump administration
global entry and then the revocation of that global entry that
Hassan's speech and his disposition on issues did not play a
role in that that oh it just so happened that in this one month
interim they found something sketchy that wasn't related to anything
that you got internet that's based sorry um no no you're probably
fine I think kick is actually now riy so I don't know if you're
watching. I think kick is actually up. So, I'm my kick dashboard
basically won't pop up right now. We'll see. I don't know if
chat's going to work well. We'll see how it goes.
Same related problem is when you get into an argument over stupid
like dog warts. Wait, did you have another comment up somewhere
or
no? Okay. Good speech. All right. That's what you have to believe.
Number one. Oh, you guys are fine. You have to believe it.
No, the Trump administration is actively targeting people for
those beliefs. So you so that's it's not just in a normal
they're talking bragging about doing these kinds of things related
to your speech okay numerous prominent cases around the time
when Hassan's global entry is revoked right around the time that
glo his his global entry is revoked in March that's when all
this was happening well starting to happen I should say so that's
a complete coincidence so coinciding with the exact same thing
happening to different people in different contexts als also
coinciding with the exact time that they're denying global entry
to other political opponents like Chris Krebs,
former administration officials. Literally the same exact thing
that they're denying people for political reasons going after
other Yeah, Black Irish. That was basically the argument I was
making is we actually don't know that something changed between
those two things. Uh you don't know like the rates at which government
works and government could be slow in like one of these things
like let's say approving people. So, let's say the background
check happens like four months ago and then they just rubber
stamp it. Some other thing rubber stamps it now and he gets in,
right? So, it happened like way way before February and then
he gets rubber stamped in February gets it and then it's a revoked
a month later, March, right? We don't know like what actually
like I'm making the argument that it could be like speech from
a year ago that got him dinged too. I have no idea what got him
dinged specifically. Political enemies and denying global entry
specifically.
Okay. And then when he comes back, he's questioned about that
stuff specifically. So you need to believe all of that is just
a random coincidence. You are lost if you still believe that.
You are lost if you still buy that. That is garbage. That is
your Hassan blinders on for you to buy that. And it forces you
also for the people who are promoting this narrative. What happened?
Oh, his goes on board. Okay. Hassan is bad sometimes, but not
always. Okay. You can't just say Hassan is bad and that's like
the whole argument. That's not how it works.
Sorry. I mean, is that what you feel the reason is? But that
you can also feel as if it was a illegal/cary slope. Well, I
basically think that for me with the Trump administration,
I have like a zero charity policy with the Trump administration
at this point and I know that for a fact. I'm willing to be argued
out of those zero charity positions, but unfortunately
Trump derangement syndrome is like actually just the it should
be just be standard operating procedure for most like intelligent
human beings, right? Unfortunately, the people who have given
Trump charity now have had egg on their face so many times that
you would be to just give him like to just be neutral on him.
For most of the decisions of the Trump administration, I'm like,
"Oh, I believe these were done for nefarious reasons. Now you
have to show me that they weren't because like like I I'm sorry.
I just feel like as a heristic that's going to guide me in the
right direction like 100% of the time. Now I'm willing to see
any evidence and and see like I'm I'm totally fine approaching
it twice and saying well that's that's how I think basically
I'll always be correct but also just look at the evidence to
see oh maybe I have no evidence for that at all and it it's like
I I don't know that that's likely right now. But I I do think
ba more or less approaching things with like that thinking is
just going to be accurate so much more of the time at this point.
It's pretty crazy happened to this is just random random routine.
Now that's been blown out and so now there's has to be a new
narrative I guess which is that there's some unspecified
valid reason by the Trump administration to with to resend in
that month interrum where all this
anti-propalestinian
stuff is happening that this random as of yet unspecified reason
is the real reason for rescending the global entry at that point.
Give me a [__] break. If you believe that, you are
[__] lost. And it's on and on and on. Apologies for
the regime.
On and on and on.
I don't give a if Hassan
I feel like Pisco is just saying what I'm saying, which is very
funny. Okay. I think he's just saying what I'm saying where it's
like literally at this point entire entire argument always seems
to be that you will 100% agree with all of his previous ones.
Maybe kind of. I don't know. Son is evil. So, I just have no
charity for him. Okay, but where is Assan done evil? Being like
a horrible like narcissistic friend to Ethan Klein, is that evil?
I mean, if you want to call that evil, then there are so many
people that are evil that you have to basically cut out of of
everything you do for being evil. Like, it's it's that's fine,
but I don't know that does that make any difference. What do
you have to do, Admiral? Nobody. I want you to tell me Hassan
is evil, so I just have no charity for him. You tell me why he's
evil and then tell me what decisions you make about him or what
you do about him because he's evil. I'd love to hear that. Said
he loved Hitler. It's first amendment protected speech in this
country that there shall not be viewpoint discrimination. I don't
care if Assan said America deserved 911 20 times. It's called
being principled in favor of free speech for American citizens
cuz it's shit's going to happen to you, too. It's the same. Yes.
Yes. Yes. It's actually the exact same as why you want all of
those people who weren't necessar who were on green cards, right,
who are getting blackged. You probably want the first amendment
to apply to them. And you probably don't want them to be able
to get blackedged for like writing a probicle,
right? You don't you don't want that. You don't want that because
think of how when it's not BDS, when it's not Palestine, think
of how that could apply to one of your positions. Maybe you've
got some position that's kind of out there because of some personal
experience. Do you want to get black? Do you want your friends
or family to get blackedged for some random idea they have? Like
oh like we're really pro like um oh what would it be? We're really
pro- Sudan in like one of these genocides in Africa or something
and you just get like exported from the country. You just get
uh deported from the country, right? Exported. Jesus. Like it's
it's so
This happened when um I think it was Aristocracy was on Twitter
and was complaining about um I think she was complaining about
some person and she was arguing with Pisco and I was just like
dude just imagine like they declare the IDF a terrorist group,
right? Cuz that's that's the other issue is the State Department's
not using some rubric. The State Department just gets to say
this group's a terrorist group now. Would you want this uh this
Trump administration if they become more populist if they give
into like some if if some anti-semitic populace rises in the
United States? Okay. Would you not want them to be able to be
um restrained by the institutions? Would you want them to be
able to say, "Oh, the IDF, Israel is a terrorist organization,
a country that promotes terrorism." Actually, the IDF's a terrorist
organization. The MSAD are terrorists. Okay? Any support for
Israel or the IDF, that's terrorist. That's proterrorism. That's
giving sucker or aid to the enemies of the United States, you
can go to jail for that now. They can totally do that. They have
every avenue to possibly to do that, right? They can totally
do that. That is legal. That is well within the government's
legal right. and they could start deporting people. Okay. Black
bag is the same as no fastpass. No, it's obviously much worse.
Is fast TSA? No, Cherry. It's not. It's not. But what is a part
of the first amendment is your ability to say some and not get
your rights taken, not get sorry, not get your rights, not lose
things based on your first amendment, right, from the government.
Not private entities, from the government. If this was Hassan
getting kicked off of Twitch, Pisco would not be sitting here
going, "Oh, that's like uh that's like our government failing.
He wouldn't be doing that, right? It's a government institution
discriminating against Assad based on his political viewpoint."
That's the problem. Rationale that I offer from Mahmud Khalil,
for Mea Our for all these other cases where I don't have to cosign
what they're saying. I don't have to cosign their beliefs. What
I'm standing up for is rights. And you guys are lost. You're
like, "Oh, yeah. I guess it's it's like the Supreme Court. I
suppose there could be some legitimate purpose that they could
come up with. We can't look at all of the surrounding context
and come to a reasonable conclusion. So, can we at least put
away this whole randomness thing, right? They sent him a letter
telling them that it was revoked
and you have to buy, you have to believe. So, that's that's one
quote is this whole there's a valid reason, but we just don't
know what that reason is and we're not going to specify it and
it's has nothing to do with the speech. has nothing to do with
the time. This would be more equal if Assan was on a nofly list.
Um I maybe but it's still it's still a problem. It's still obviously
a problem. Is kick not working? No. Apparently kicks for everybody.
Period in which they're already imposing restrictions both on
um citizens with respect to global entry for political enemies
and they're doing it on the basis of speech with viewpoint discrimination
for other contexts. Okay. And it's a short window of time. So
pretty convenient that in that interim that happens. Pretty convenient,
I'd have to say. Unbelievably convenient. And if it's some valid
reason, I mean, the government hasn't told us.
What if you misspelled his name? Yeah, honestly, Pisco's position
is a little more tenuous than I expected it to expected it to
be. I do think there's like Yeah, a lot of government delay possibilities.
And yeah, I do think it's like it's entirely possible that the
government has like up in some way that he doesn't even see here
that it doesn't tie to pro Palestinian positions at all. I think
that's entirely possible. I don't think I think this argument
is a little too strong here in my opinion that he's saying, "Oh,
it's" he's kind of just going, "Oh, really?" This is It's never
good when you're like, "No, you really think you you really think
that just because so you really think that it's possible that
it's anything else? You really think so? You really think that?
Uhhuh. This is literally the kind of what have you misspelled,
right? Like that's what I don't I honestly can't tell if it's
ironic or not. Yeah. He's just he's basically saying like like
Okay, so take every
like this. What if he misspelled his name? And you compound them
all together and I think you get over like whatever percentage
it is that it's pro Palestinian speech that got his taken away,
right? Is he taking a libertarian position? Um,
I think he's just taking a pro- First Amendment position. I don't
know if I'd call it libertarian. I don't know if Pisco is a libertarian.
It's just like, no, this is a this is a civil liberty that has
to be protected at all costs. So, he is protecting a civil liberty,
but I wouldn't really call it libertarian in my opinion, but
that's what they would have you believe that it's just random
coincidence. Random. And then, right, you have to you have to
put in there the questioning. Oh, this questioning.
I guess that questioning is random, too. Well, hold on, Hunter.
But you don't put you don't put that art. It's not like that
argument. I'd say that argument is obviously like very very low
chance, right? But it's like every single procedural mistake
that could happen. Every single thing that's like that's like
something Hassan said
the Houthy and before March, right? Every single comment Hassan's
made that's insane, but it's not related to Israel. I would say
you put all those together, you group them up as one possible
thing, and it's like, well, I I think that's probably at least
as likely or maybe even more likely than his pro Palestinian
rhetoric getting his taken away. probably
cuz cuz remember there's the other cope which is well this shows
that he wasn't stopped because of viewpoint discrimination. He
was just stopped because he was in the wrong line. Well the only
reason he's in the wrong line is because of viewpoint discrimination
even if that were the rationale. So it's turtles all the way
down. If it's based on okay but no
what? Sorry. If that if that was the reason he got stopped because
he's just in the wrong line, then that's like that's but that's
it's not some policy in the book where they're restricting speech
necessarily. Viewpoint discrimination that he's in the wrong
line. Then it's viewpoint discrimination.
But even put that aside's position is just just that it's viewpoint
discrimination. Well, there would be some some aspects of Assan's
rhetoric that is not about his viewpoint really. Like when he
just posts that picture uh toward like in response to Tom Cotton,
that's not a viewpoint. That's not protected speech. That is
like incitement. That is that's like right at the line of incitement.
I think you'd actually argue that's incitement. It's insane that
Hassan wasn't banned for that to be honest with you. If he's
just in the wrong line, you direct him to the next line, right?
Why would you detain him? Why would you detain him and then ask
him questions about the very thing that we're all here for, which
are the That's probably Pisco's best argument in in
response is that why did they ask him about all of this stuff
if this wasn't a part of their concern with him being in Global
Entry, the Global Entry program? Why would they ask him about
his streams? Why would they ask him about his support for other
groups? Why would they be doing that? Right. He's approved for
Global Entry after that post. Yes, Porter Beller. That is assuming
that the government would have had all of the information up
to the up to date and that they wouldn't be operating on like
old information or they they wouldn't be like delayed in picking
up new stuff at all. That they would be like up to the moment
that they would be keeping up on this in the same way that like
a Twitch watcher would insane to me. Like obviously the government
would be delayed a little bit, right? What did Tom Cotton post?
Doesn't matter. Doesn't matter. Tom Tom Cotton could have posted,
"I want I want the president of the United States hurt in like
this specific. I want the president of the United Hypothetically,
Tom Cotton could have said something like,"I want the president
of the United States right now." And it still wouldn't be okay
for Assan to post death threats towards Tom Cotton. Okay? You
can't just call for death threats on somebody you perceive is
going uh is calling for death threats of their own. You can't
do that. That's not cool. Viewpoints, which is the politics.
If at this point with the evidence that's that that's been presented
so far your take is
I can't like more likely than not who's to say or more likely
than not it's not viewpoint discrimination you are lost.
You will buy anything this government tells you. You will literally
buy anything this government tells you. See this is the thing
is I I struggle because I'm like dude I do agree with like you
you just don't trust this government at all. This government's
like totally you don't trust them at all.
But I I also think like I don't like the way Pesco is arguing
it in general. I do not like when we do this argument of like,
"Oh, you really you really think that?" You'd have to be stupid
to think that. You really with like no evidence at all. You're
just like, "Dude, you're you're telling me that given like the
government is like totally against pro Palestinian speech that
they've like deported people over this stuff. You're telling
me that you don't believe this had to do with like a a rights
violation. You're telling me this wasn't a like a viewpoint.
This wasn't viewpoint discrimination. No. No. That's not Pisco's
entire debate style. That's wrong. Yeah, I understand that, Hunter.
I understand that. But the issue is they could say this is open
to our discretion. But unfortunately, if again, I'm just gonna
It's the same argument Pisco gave. Shockingly,
I just I haven't done a lot of looking into this, so it's shockingly
to me that the Pisco made the same argument I did. But it's like
if if they were just collecting all black people there and bring
them all in for screening, you wouldn't say it's just at their
discretion, right? Even if they didn't say an overt policy. So
Pisco is arguing they've shown discrimination to these views.
They've shown that they're willing to engage in viewpoint discrimination.
So, I believe it was viewpoint discrimination.
It's not in reality, it's not a strong argument, but it's like
I think when you pair it, maybe when you pair it with the fact
that they asked him about his viewpoints in the interview, you
can almost get there. You can almost get there. It's like I can
reach out and I can almost touch it. And I'm very curious if
anyone will No, they're both constitutionally violative, Hunter.
You understand that, right? They're both constitutionally violative.
come on voice to defend it at this point given the evidence you
are starting with the conclusion here and working backward no
listen listen so it's very clear right he is there's wait he
totally is he totally is he totally is starting with the conclusion
and working backwards
I'm sorry that's that is what's happening here that's actually
what Pisco does most of I will say and uh somebody can quote
me on this somebody could send this to Pisco if they want I do
believe Pisco usually starts from the conclusion he wants and
works backwards Pisco is an advocate he is a an activist and
an advocate and he starts from the position he wants to have
and works backwards to find out how to argue for it in the most
effective way possible. And I know that that's most people consider
like would consider that a accusation of bad faith. I just consider
him like an activist. Okay, I think he absolutely does that.
That is totally true. Not only is he doing that, but he's taking
a victory lap and he's completely vindicated. That's pretty smug.
Well, nobody's ever accused Pisco of not being smug. Okay. Not
a single person ever.
the granting of global entry. Global entry has been granted.
Okay. You think Pisco is permab bad faith? No. I don't think
he I don't think he argues backwards and finds arguments that
are like clearly not in good faith and uses them necessarily,
but I do think he tries to find the strongest arguments for the
positions that he wants to have 100%. I don't think he goes in
I don't think he goes in thinking like I'm only sorry, how should
I put this? I think I think he goes in he's like I want to argue
this position. I want to be on this side. Okay, I'm going to
work backwards from that and then I'm going to run this front
to back again and see if it works, right? But I do think it starts
at a fundamental basis from the conclusion he wants. Okay? And
then in a short amount of time, right around when all of these
anti- Palestine actions, anti-Palestine uh protester action is
happening, it's rescended for Hassan at a time when they're announcing
that they're searching social medias. They're announcing they're
looking into people's uh for whether or not they support Israel
Palestine. They're announcing that they're rescending global
entry for enemies and then when it you can't try to argue that
he is bad faith but use arguments from Dan Saltman.
Who are you talking to? Borsing Yonko
who in the Wait, hold on. That must be a reply, right? You're
replying to somebody else. No, you just said that at a base.
Okay, cool. All right. Ultimately comes at the border when he
stopped. He's questioned about the Yeah, exactly. evil Johnny
Bravo. This I've I've talked about this a little bit with uh
with some people. I think that's just like naturally what a lawyer
does, right? That's a lawyer is an advocate for some position.
This person is innocent. This person is guilty. They're like
an advocate and they work backwards from there, right? That is
what they do. Yeah. 100%. Post the evidence the application was
approved. Okay. So, here's here's a question, Sharpie. What does
revoke mean?
What does revoke mean? Well, one is Hassan says that it was granted.
That's evidence. He said it was granted. If it wasn't granted,
why would they be emailing him to say it was
right? Like I Yeah, denied obviously is what they would say.
It's his testimony that it's granted. But what does the term
revoke mean for you? I want to skip past this. Your application
was revoked. It's I'm reading it. It doesn't You can revoke an
application.
Oh, Sharpie, what are you talking about? Sharpie's in our Discord.
That's not a good one, buddy. That's not Oh my goodness. You
can He says you can revoke an application. So, it's an assumption.
Oh, sorry. That is This isn't hard. You can revoke an application.
This isn't hard.
Come on.
What are we doing? Say your application was revoked. It's I'm
reading it. After careful review, we have determined that your
Global Entry program membership was revoked. Oh, it Sharpie,
you you actually earned that one. I'm sorry. You earned it. You
earned it. That's a rough one. And then you have people. Good.
Yeah. Good. Yeah. You guys are idiots.
You're claiming to know and it doesn't necessarily mean what
you're saying. So ju just to be clear, these are like the kind
of people who would see the government legalize like uh soldiers
civilian women. Um they would see that like get legalized because
they actually are, you know, a part of whatever party that is
currently in government. They'd see soldiers like their enemies
sisters and they'd be like, "That's so awesome. That's so cool."
And then three years later when their mom and sister are getting
raped, they'd be like, "Oh, this is the worst violation ever.
This is horrible." No, that's why you have to have principles,
okay? That's why you actually have to think things uh think of
things as if how they would be used on you in some way. Morons.
That's literally Pisco. It's not literally Pisco. He's literally
arguing the opposite of that right now. Okay. If I tell you that
your membership at Denny's has been revoked,
what do English speakers take that? First of all, Hassan says
he got the card. Hassan says it was granted. I believe him when
he says that. I actually do believe him cuz I just went through
the process and it's very clear when you've been accepted for
Global Entry. And there's evidence of that. I'm sure he has the
card somewhere. It's a weird thing to lie about. Guys, if you're
watching on Kick, uh you can go to Twitch to chat, okay? I noticed
Kick is like totally stalling out right now. Don't worry about
chatting Twitch. I'll see both messages. Okay, I can see that
everything's all right. I see it. I know. I see. Just to be clear,
it's fine. So, I number one that is evidence of it is he says
it and I I'm sure that there's documentary evidence to attest
to that. But even put that aside. Take the following sentence.
After careful review, we have determined that your Global Entry
program membership was revoked because you do not meet the guidelines
for program participation. Does that say your application was
denied
or does that say that your program membership was revoked? Sharpie,
stop arguing. What are you doing?
Right. Hold on. I actually I had another time stamp here for
this. I should denying Oh, no. We got a that he was detained
at all. People still deny that. And I think I was going to skip
forward to some VC debates and try to see what was going on here.
I think we want to skip forward to some VC debates. See what
happens. Wants to set up a confront. Okay, we got some VC. people
is that we think more likely than none and I agree with you that
the revocation is due to viewpoint discrimination. That's going
to affect our prior on whether or not the questioning has to
do with viewpoint discrimination. So if hold on back it up a
little more. Okay, we're into Collins here. We're going to get
into Collins right here. Okay.
Global entry is a voluntary program your membership in global
Trump. Somebody's going to join and he said he was
okay.
So he just All right. You just got blown the [__]
out. Okay. The [__] is a Denny's membership? What
is he talking about? Listen, lots of people have a Denny's membership.
How did I unfollow Denny's membership? I'm extremely fat. Okay.
Well, base Leon lost. So, he acknowledges conditional approval
in 2024. And he said he was he got a full approval notice on
26, February 6th. So, you admit that it's likely discrimination,
correct? Yeah. And it's most certainly viewpoint discrimination.
I just hadn't seen him say that. I had seen. It's a heads up.
I join at 153 and it's a long call. Also, I don't know if it's
worth it to go all the way through if you do Collins later. Um,
I might do Collins at some point here. I mean, I guess I would
do Collins like relatively close to now, but we'd have to see
exactly I want to hear the dates and stuff. So, I'm going to
hear him walk through this with somebody real quick. Other things
that
he's gotten distinguish himself. Appreciate it. Hey, thank you.
But also, I think Yudi's coming on a little bit to do reading
of vlogs. So, yeah. Once she's around, I'm probably going to
skip over the pirate software stuff. Yeah, I am happy to have
the argument, but I just want to point out that I wasn't trying
to argue that it wasn't viewpoint discrimination. I was trying
to get you to agree that if he was lying about the whole thing
that it would not have been viewpoint discrimination. We kind
of got a little off the sauce. No, but if if he lied about the
whole thing, right? If he lied about literally everything there,
it almost doesn't make sense because the government has acknowledged
that he was detained and the government has I guess if he So,
so like even if he lied about everything, I don't think that
it like logically precludes me from being right, but I agree
that it would make the case much weaker. All right. No, it doesn't
stop you from being right. I was just saying that like if he
had full-blown global entry, you were 100% correct. There's no
chance that you could possibly be wrong really. I can't think
of a reason why it wouldn't be viewpoint discrimination. Like
what has he done that would get his global entry revoked? Like
that'd be weird. Yeah, it was like within a month, right? So
this is February 6th and like March within a month of Trump taking
office too. So it's absolutely like somebody targeting him. I
think that lines up with that like like beyond a reasonable doubt.
But if he didn't have full-blown global entry, if he was still
on conditional approval and no, even then even then, right, why
would the conditional approval be revoked in in that case, unless
you I think the more likely answer would be that it was because
of um discrimination
as opposed to I saw somebody saying here that like he went to
an interview but he forgot his passport or something. Like if
that was the case and then he just never reschedled his interview
and then they were just like like you don't want this, go away.
Like I think that would be a reasonable thing that they might
do. Might violate the terms of his approval, whatever. I'm I'm
throwing something out there, okay? because I I Yeah, like that
might not be obviously that isn't what happened, but like that
could be a reason, right? Like he just didn't schedule interview
properly. Yeah, it could be a reason. I don't think it's like
one though, but I appreciate you coming on. That's going to be
the thing is you're not going to come up with like a better single
explanation. And I agree with Pisco that the best single explanation
is probably viewpoint discrimination. But the problem is that
realistically the evidence we have probably puts that up to like
10 20%.
And there's like 80% is all the other things, but all the other
things are like maybe 30% I would say even, but all the other
things put together are like still like moral uncertainty.
And the issue is you just can't find a better one, right?
Shut it up. There is no other singular didn't have global entry
and then he went through global entry line and then was stopped.
That wouldn't be viewpoint discrimination, right? Um if he was
No, the stop for being on the wrong line wouldn't be viewpoint
discrimination. But the question could still be that's all I
was saying. But the question it could still be cuz Pisco unironically
says that the other things is 1%. That's where you go to a betting
thing, right? You'd say, "Pisco, okay, give me 99 to1 odds on
doing this stuff." I'm not sure if you still plan on covering
any Destiny stuff, but he also made fun of you a few days ago.
Don't know if you've seen it. Don't know about that. Uh, you
could throw a clip in the Discord somewhere.
There's stream chat. You throw a Discord clip in there um if
you want me to react to it. But yeah, I have no idea, not a clue
what you're talking about. So, good luck. I just I hadn't seen
them say that he had got make that distinction though finger
[__] and once he has made that distinction then that
tells me that I mean he could be still be lying but more likely
than not he's not okay but the fact that he's picking a specific
date you know like I would say like the unreasonable doubt is
pointing with you appreciate that man thank you so much thank
you for being reasonable and thank you for I know I shouted at
you I just was getting a little frustrated but yeah thank you
and uh keep on watching later later all right so complete vindication
continues so now we have even more evidence right so Hassan here
is acknowledging that he understands the difference between conditional
approval and full approval he gives a specific date for when
full approval happened. That's 26 2025. And so you have to believe
in that interim, that one-month interim that something happened
after he was granted full approval, which of course the letter
by itself says it revoked his full membership into the Global
Entry program, right? You have to believe that something valid,
some non-spech related thing happened right at this period of
time in which the administration is going full uh you 10 toes
down, whatever the phrase is on all of these policies related
to immigration, on all the
Sorry, me there's a clip. Gotta be careful celebrating your air
defense superiority. Okay. Gotta be very
Just they took just out. They took him out. [__]
me.
That's an awesome clip. Thank you very much for that. Thank you
very much for that. We appreciate it. We appreciate it. Continue
on with this stuff. It's just be beyond the pale to think that
this is just not related. Beyond the pale. Um okay. So other
copers, if you're a coper, please come into the stream disagreements
and we'll we'll we'll chat it out and we'll talk more about this
and why you think that this is not viewpoint discrimination.
We'll go to gauntlet next. I see gauntlet in the disagreements.
Yeah, this is going to be this is just going to be really hard
because like there's so little evidence and Pisco probably has
what I would say is the strongest one. I just if he was going
to go 991 then you just have to offer the bet, right? You give
me like 99 to1 odds the other way and I don't think he would
ever do that. like he would or or he would do that on like 10
bucks. Give me 90 out of one odds and 10 bucks. What can I do
for you? Oh, hello. How you doing? I agree. I disagree with your
Hassan take. Okay. Why? Um, okay. Let's get a couple facts straight.
So, we're living in the same reality. Okay. I agree. Hassan had
global entry temporarily approved. I agree. He had it fully approved
in February and he had it revoked in March. Right. Okay. I also
agree Hassan was detained. Okay. Also, according to Han himself,
this is his first time in global entry. Okay. Yes. Okay. So
then when looking at when going over Hassan's video, he said
um they took their passports after they stopped him and they
did further research on everybody. And that's when afterwards
they called his name which shows I think and I think you said
initially when you went over it that they weren't choosing him
specifically that they chose that they just chose him as a part
of a stop. No, I think more I think more likely than not he was
stopped because he was flagged before before anything. So I I've
said that I've said it's like 55% you know my my intuition on
that is like you know 55 to 60% that he was stopped because of
a flag. Um but certainly the questioning I think is above and
beyond that that they fly to at some point. But but regardless
at some point in this age if you put discrimination and I think
that the revocation now the revocation which is established and
that you seem to agree is established that that revocation is
more likely than not be discrimination. Do you agree with that?
Um I'm not sure I have enough evidence to agree on that point.
I just want to I want to run through a few more things. What
C money? What are you talking about? Did see Did you just send
like an extremely old chat or something? Let's frame it as Tommy
C versus Chud Logic for you, JCO. How does that change your viewpoint?
I don't know what you're what the are you responding to? Ignore.
Okay. Thank god that I'm super lost. I'm like, what the We can
agree on that. He's lied about some stuff. A lot of people lie
about stuff. He lies about Okay. Yeah, but I'm just saying some
of your favorite content creators have lied about stuff. No,
I know. I'm just saying in general, I I think we could probably
agree that Hassan is propagates misinformation purposely a lot
of the I think we can agree on that. I think that he he has done
that. I think he has done that. Yeah. Okay. Then we can also
agree that he exaggerated using words like detention center when
it's just like a side room they bring in like the at TSA or whatever,
right? It's it's a detention room. I don't know. Detention space.
I don't know. But he in his video he was clearly trying to make
it sound like they witness. He was embellishing. He was he was
Yeah. talking it up. Okay. And we can also agree that he lied
about the timeline, right? I think I think more like I think
more like than not he he lied about the amount of time. Mhm.
Because he we've seen in multiple videos why would that that
literally him lying about the amount of time isn't even like
a moral wrong. It's him embellishing him being a he's changed
the amount of time and then once he got pushed back and bad empanada
and no Samson questioned him about the timeline he go sorry embellishing
him being a victim not a overused that word a lot embellishing
him being a victim. Uh, who cares? Nobody cares. Like, it doesn't
matter, right? Yeah.
Okay. So, when we look at the line of questioning, Hassan goes
in and he says the first question he was asked, he's like, "Oh,
what are you doing in Chicago?" And then Hassan replied and he
said, "I had a speaking engagement about journalism." Yeah. According
to Hassan, the person you say is a liar. Yes. But yes. Yes. Yes.
Well, okay. Uh, I'm just saying that this doesn't lead to credibility.
That's all I'm saying. But you can I'm just going through what
he's saying. Okay. Then he goes, "Okay, what do you speak about?"
And Hassan says, "Twitch." And then the person says, "What do
you do on Twitch?" And Hassan says, "You know, games, politics,
drama." And then he goes, you talk about the news. Does this
seem like out of the ordinary for an agent that's questioning
you? When you bring up when they ask you what you're doing and
then you bring up your job, is it out of the ordinary for them
to question along the lines of your job? Especially if you're
offering information
um like readily like Hassan was. Yeah. So I think it's out of
the ordinary the question embellished his victimhood.
Sure. I broitis.
Thank you. Thank you for the donation. Thank you for the bits.
I appreciate that you omitted the questions that are appreciate
you. I would agree with you that those are weird if they started
off like that. But it start he started off by asking what are
you doing in Chicago and Han open saying that he's there for
a speaking engagement about journalism and then it goes down
this line of Twitch and then games and politics and then and
then he asked about the news. The thing is part of this conclusion
part of my conclusion about what's most likely is informed by
the revocation.
Isn't it? It must be.
I I don't know. Okay. Here can we can we can we agree on this
about the revocation? Do we have an explicit reason for why global
entry was revoked? They don't list an explicit reason. It's up
to us to come to what's the most likely scenario. Okay? And so
I'm going to ask you what the most likely scenario is and you're
going to be uncomfortable because I'm going to it's going to
be obvious. No, I'll bite the bullet. I'll bite the bullet. I
would agree cuz I hate Trump, too. Okay. I'm a hate Trump hater.
I agree. Okay. The the unhinged like destruction of free speech
in this country. It makes sense that Trump would do this. Okay.
I I'll say that completely. I'm going to ask you I'm going to
ask you what is the most likely scenario for why his global entry
was revoked between when it was granted in February 6th and when
it was revoked in early March. What's the most likely scenario?
I will lean towards some sort of viewpoint discrimination. However,
however, my question I'm I I don't lean 100% towards that or
I I lean like 60 70% towards that only because why would they
grant it to him in February after Trump had already taken office?
Why would they grant it to him in February a month later? Because
first of all, it's very close in time to his inauguration. There
was still like in early February, they were still wrapping their
arms around the administration. they were taking control of it
and a lot of the big policies that were these big speech policies
you know the revocation of student visa green cards that happened
like in March in early March right around this occurring right
so early on I could imagine this being in the process and they're
just going through the normal process and it being granted because
it's just like some jobber who's doing all this stuff and then
um you know a month passes by and now the administration is in
full gear revoking global entry for Chris Krebs uh revoking Mahmood
Khalil going after Mu Khalil going after my Auster going after
um you know the student vis situation and right in that period
when they're doing all this stuff when they're revoking global
entry of their other political enemies when they're imposing
their first amendment restrictions and then they revoke global
entry of their other political enemies. Who are their other political
enemies? So Chris Krebs, who who the is that Chris Krebs, sorry,
I didn't know who this was, Hunter, when you mentioned it earlier.
Former United States director of cyber security infrastructure
and uh and security agency.
Caesar Democrat, I'm guessing. No, he was appointed by Trump.
That's what I don't remember. Yeah, I don't know who this in
charge of election security in 2020. Okay. He was a lifelong
Republican dude that was targeted by an executive order. Okay.
Jesus.
All right. At that point when the policy has ratcheted up and
when the Secretary of State comes out and says all the things
he says, you know, Marco Rubio about anti-terrorist speech, all
that, that's when it's revoked. So, I think that's more than
a coincidence. And so, I I don't have a problem. Yeah. In February,
early February, it was a, you know, transition. The administration
hadn't gotten its grounds yet. It's still implementing its vision,
but it's its true vision about stomping on free speech and stomping
on um descent with respect to immigration. that really starts
to come to a head in early March and that's when all these big
cases come. Okay. Sure. Now, here's my next question. Are there
reasons on this is like actually difficult for me cuz like I
do think that there's every reason to believe this happened and
realistically again going back I I believe that you might as
well operate under that assumption cuz every time you give charity
to the Trump administration, you end up looking for Okay. But
at the same time, I just I really hate that. I don't know. There's
something going on here. There's like a pattern going on here
where it's like I do agree with Pisco's like conclusion, but
the argumentation style then like uh kind of getting it. It's
a little weird to me in combination. That's all on the grounds
of like on first uh like on on speech grounds that you can validly
revoke global entry
um on speech grounds. I don't know what you mean by that. On
view
a view like there's like if Hassan like literally like went on
Twitch or something and said I want to murder Donald Trump.
Right. Right. So what you can't favor what you can't favor is
one class of speaker on an issue versus another class of speaker.
That's the essence of view discrimination is to disfavor a class
of speaker because of their particular viewpoint on an issue
specifically political issue. Now, if you say I want to shoot
D, I think that can be taken as a also um I don't know where
I want to skip over cuz I this is mostly treading ground that
I've already thought through and like that I'm not super interested
in. But I don't want to get off of this, but I also know apparently
apparently like I just missed listen like I don't know if um
how do I put it? Nobody's really interested in Destiny anymore.
He apparently went live and like talked about me and I didn't
even hear about it until today. Oh, but I was gone, wasn't I?
No, I wasn't gone. Why didn't anybody tell me about this? What
the Sorry, I'm just I'm thinking I might look at this clip. I
looked at the transcript just to see what it was about real quick.
I don't know. You guys check the docket. Have there been? Let
me Let me look. What's going on real quick? Check in on this
stuff. Docket. Docket. Docket. Do it. Do it. Do it. Do it. Nope.
Just their from the last filing they had to correct for help.
Uh,
with 10 gifted, let's go. It's another hour on the stream. Thank
you very much, Cyberdrifter. Appreciate it. Appreciate you. 3
hours 3 minutes 11 seconds. Boom. There it is. Let's go. Let's
go. To be fair, you talked a lot of on him and he gets a couple
hits back. Uh, hits back on what?
Okay, here's the prediction. Okay, drama 101. He's going to get
some hits back by basically not showing any clips of me and characterizing
what I said without ever actually addressing what was said. But
he will make up what I said. Okay? He'll totally mischaracterize
what I said. He'll make some up and then he will go on with his
day, right? Like he will talk to an uh as in using his own words
a similac he won't actually analyze my position. He won't actually
show what I'm saying. Uh he won't do any of that, right? He'll
do the exact thing he criticized Assan and Vos for doing to him
and he'll do that directly to me.
Listening to I'm trying not to give I shouldn't be giving these
people any attention. But now this guy talks about me like the
same amount I talk about him is very funny. Which is kind of
funny. He always says this every time too. I shouldn't give these
people attention. How many times has he started a segment of
trying to talk about me going, "Man, I shouldn't I really should
not be giving this guy attention right now, you know? I should
I shouldn't give this guy attention right now. Some guy was pressing
uh some guy was pressing a hater on his stream a lot about like
why don't you come out and join Pixie's case
and just go ahead. He's got a clip. He's going to show a clip.
Oh my god. He's going to show a clip. He's going to show a clip
right now. They're joined. They're going to kill me. He's like
He's trying to pretend that he's like actually afraid of for
his life. I think they're going to people are going to they're
going to kill me. He's already audience. I'm sorry. He's going
to they're going to kill me. meanwhile like was covering this
space. Uh I said there's reason to be concerned that I could
be under threat like actual serious threat from his audience
cuz his audience are incelss with nothing to live for. That's
why they watch him. Right. That was the argument. Yeah. I could
your your audience has nothing to lose and nothing to live for.
I'm That's terrifying when when the person who's their cult leader
is like, "Yeah, you guys should kill this guy." Absolutely. Yep.
Yeah. That's totally true. Uh he is a totally like a a totally
like uh how would you put it? Like like a totally flaccid, ineffective
limp loser that could never do anything physical with anybody.
He has less testosterone than most women. Uh I don't has he ever
gotten to be able to bench plate bench press like a plate? He's
just a total loser. He's not a threat to anybody physically himself.
Um he has all of these guns. Uh, this I'm assuming this is like
him trying to seem cool or threatening in some way is embarrassing.
It's so embarrassing to look at this person.
Basically, daily. I don't know. I just thought that was hilarious.
But everybody was asking him because I remember when this all
started, Jessica was like, "Oh, I know so much information about
everything going on in the background. You guys are going to
[__] your pants." And then um I knew that other women
were uh had their sentent non-consensually. And that's a part
of the case now. And Destiny's only response to that every time
it happens is literally, "Oh, this is not relevant to the case."
No, he never ever addresses whether or not it happened, right?
He's, "This isn't relevant. Why are you bringing this up right
now?" Now, people are like, "Well, why don't you join the case?"
Like, "Wouldn't this be so important?" Because they're clearly
flailing. And he's like, "Oh, he'll mention that I said like,
oh, I obviously like have basically information I made public,
right?" And I think I said to this guy like with regards to Pixie's
case, no, I don't have more information. Like with regards to
Pixie case, do I have like private information that I have not
made public? I don't think so. I'm pretty sure I haven't. I have
to go through look through anything I like said to Pixie, but
I don't think so. But Pixie's case is not the only case. That
was what we're all alluding to. Why is he pretending he doesn't
understand that? They're clearly flailing. He said, "Oh, okay.
Like, I've already said everything I know publicly. What? Like,
what more can I do? There's no point in me." These clips are
like 20 minutes long, so I don't know.
person would do it if I was in your in your position. Can you
think of he's playing a clip exercise? If you if you are thinking
about this um why let's say you believe what you believe why
would you still say that you can't speak right? Why why would
you go and do that? Why would you say you can't speak on it unless
you get my It's weird that you went to say that he committed
crimes should he like that was a weird weird just answer it.
I don't think I mean charge crimally. Are we talking about this
specific case? [__] I didn't bookmark anything.
I'm going to die if I join this case. they could
like. Okay. Oh, I think he's he's probably seething because he
wants to paint this as not a real death threat. Right. That's
actually what their entire motion was based on was that I didn't
believe it was a serious threat. So, he's probably actually just
seething that I confirmed it is a serious threat that I do take
seriously and now that argument holds no water. Right. That's
probably what he's actually upset about. He literally called
for your docs and said he wanted to. Yes. He said he would get
he said as soon as he gets my docs he will publish it and then
he published some random dude's docs like that's that's what
it's about. Why is he being a [__] What's the timeline
case? Same as it always has been. However long until we can do
summary judgement. I think you have to wait for the discovery
phase to end. Oh the best part about this is he might have before
I guess Abby. So he thinks Abby was like a last minute witness.
I don't believe that to be the case. And he he could have done
summary judgment. And what he actually did was he was too cheap
to pay Andy B. Okay. He was too cheap to pay Andy B to file a
motion for summary judgement before Abby had joined the case.
And probably they could have gotten the Cardi claim dismissed.
Okay. Before summary judgement. Now, realistically, then Abby
comes forward and then it goes and it goes back to they could
just refile again probably. But I think he had a chance to get
that dismissed, get it thrown out, get like his reputation restored
to some extent. And he probably is just seething that now he's
paying Andy B to like oppose a motion to file excess pages, oppose
a motion to like um get Pixie's revenge taken down. He could
have just not opposed Andy B filing for summary judgement early
on, not tried to save that, I don't know, 5 10,000 bucks. And
that decision has cost him a lot of money so far. I don't know
when the discovery phase ends or what the date is on that, but
I still need to work on all that. Me. Oh, now it's all summary
judgment. Didn't he say it will never get to discovery? Yeah,
I think he his original thing is this will be dismissed in like
a week, guys. This will be dismissed in a week. Wasn't that like
I'll let you know in a week when this is dismissed,
guys. Like a week or two, this will be dismissed. We're going
to be good to go. We'll get on with our political everything.
All right, we're fine. But this doesn't strike any DJ, right?
At all. Hold on. TJA says, "Destiny, he banned me because and
said to come back in a few months when this began because he
was certain he would get convicted."
Um, I said I was pretty confident he would get charged, but that's
has nothing to do with Pixie's case. Yeah, that has nothing to
do with Pixie's case. A couple of these cases, like for example,
Molina's case, that's open and shut. That's like bolted on. It's
done already, right? Like if Molina filed, she could absolutely
win this case. Molina won't file because she's terrified of destiny
obviously, but like she would she has an open and shut case.
There a couple other people with like an open and shut case.
Pixie is not one of them. Uh some of them have not haven't come
forward. Some of them haven't filed civil suits. We'll see how
it goes. Some people just don't have the resources to file civil
suits. Right. Anyway, we keep going. Bro went from Piers Morgan
and Medi Hassan to debating a Humeal on all Arabia English. Well,
he still does Piers Morgan from time to time to be fair to him.
I thought I was getting a skitso email. Okay, he's not talking
more about me then, right? It's like over. Well, because I get
sometimes schizophrenics from my email and they send me crazy,
but I never mind. I understand now. I know things have been rough
lately and I want you to know that I'm completely with you. Z
was 1 billion% disappointed and unamused with Jay. The only thing
I think your interpretation is missing is that the applicants
were to fill the position of K's partner. That's why he had the
final say in who to pick rather than just sucking Z to let him
in. True. Okay.
I'm guessing he's done. So, we didn't get anything played here.
You just got my charact my position characterized again. This
is because what I claim I've said never lines up with what Ian
claims I've said because he's often engaging in bad faith when
quoting my views. If you're a member of this Ian guy sounds like
a bad dude's community, it probably does feel like I'm gaslighting
you when I say I haven't done these things or they're being misrepresented
because just pretend this is me and instead of Vos's community,
I say DGG.
Vosch
does that. Destiny literally does that to me constantly. I I
will never match the caricature or the the similacer that he's
created to represent who I am. I will never align with that because
that is an object, a caricature created with no reference to
anything I've ever said or done. Boom. Man, it's so easy. Oh,
I actually have never seen this tweet before. I don't even know
how old this is. Apparently, April, January, February, March,
April. Oh. Oh, hold on. What is this? Ian claims my subreddit
literally acts like Kiwi farmers and makes fun of their lack
of adherence to reality. This is extra ironic given that Ian
subre is the one that was dinged by the admins for harassment.
Given that this is extra ironic given that Destiny's community
is the one that has a notorious reputation online for harassment.
It's It's like he literally read all of his complaints about
Vos, right? All of his complaints about Vos. He like literally
reread them and was like, "I this is what I need to do to this
guy." It's goofy. It's so goofy. Anyway, maybe the the Chloe
All right. All right. All right.
Anyway, what actually gets said will never match up with what
Desi's caricature of me is. It's amazing. Also,
just at a base level, he's like this guy that I like threatened
to dox, tried to dox, and then called for the death of is acting
like he might actually get harmed in all of this if I learn his
identity. He's acting like he might get harmed. Just think about
that on a base level. Okay? Think about that statement. This
guy who I've said I want the the docs of, who I've said I will
publish his docs immediately, who I have failed doxed at least
once. I haven't been paying attention. Okay, that guy. That guy.
He's pretending like I might try to harm him if I learn his name.
Yeah, I I think that. Yes, I do. I do think that. I do think
it's like pretty scary that you have tried to do this repeatedly,
that you brigade my Discord, that you do all this to harass and
then and then you're acting like oh no, no, no. You You're not
scared of me because you're behind a pseudonym online. So that
means you're not scared of me knowing your real life
like info at all. I
only present when they I think I think we're done with this.
I think this is all we had here. I thought he was going to play
like a clip or something. Yeah, I I don't think so. I think it's
it's just it. That's it. That's all. Okay. All right. We are
back to the Pisco versus Sansa. Threat and you're not uh just
waiting on Meowies to message me. Where's Meowies?
She said she messaged me when she's back or at least an indication
of of a potential security threat. I mean, people have
about so much less. Oh, dude. Cyberdrifter, remember when he
docks the student who basically said he's on campus and I wanted
somebody to throw an egg at him? Remember when he docks that
student because it was such a huge threat to his safety?
Yeah. Do you remember that? Apparently. Apparently, dude, this
guy, there's just no consistency here whatsoever. He's just a
complete h what a wretch, dude. What a disgusting wretch. Been
um arrested for less based on on presidents before and there's
a heightened concern, maybe even a first amendment height and
concern. God, it's actually so embarrassing.
God, the video essays that we could do on this guy are just they'd
be so funny that it would just be like that entire thing lining
up with like the the Queenman uh attempting to dox me and Queenman
saying that we should get killed, right? lying those up together
some of his positions it would be so funny with respect to those
VIPs. Um but someone who if he were to say something like Donald
Trump deserves to be in that case I would say yeah um that you
couldn't deny based on that because that would be viewpoint discrimination.
Okay. And then um sorry I
okay so and you're painting all of these cases there are some
genuinely hard cases perhaps where are you trying to disfavor
a class of speaker or is this a true threat or is this a security
rationale like there are some difficult cases for sure maybe
even somewhere I'm like I don't know but there are clear cases
right so a clear case for this would be with the following right
they couldn't deny global entry because you're a Biden supporter
right that would be right they couldn't deny you um global entry
because you support Palestine over Israel right Yeah. And they
couldn't deny you global entry because you say, "Hey, I I think
that um Trump sucks, right? The negative opinion of Trump." So,
what we're talking about here are a bunch of clear cases. Um
and I even think it extends as far as saying that, you know,
I think that the Houthies are based. If he said, I don't know
the exact words that Assange used about the Houthies, but it
extends as far as those groups. What is not protected are things
that are like already not protected by the first amendment. So
things like material material support of an international terrorist
organization like that is already not protected speech. And so
that obviously if you did that and they denied it on that basis,
that's different. But there's no evidence of that Hassan did
that. Um or for example, I know that there Oh, go ahead. Go for
it. Um so I one of the questions I have around this is um if
Han was approved previously, does that mean they did a full sweep
and they had found no issues? And if they did a further sweep
later on, could they have revoked if they found something? But
why are they looking again, right? Like why are they looking
again? That's the question, right? So, I think the fact that
they granted it, the fact that they granted it initially, right,
indicates to me if they were going to look at his past statements,
like a lot of those statements were made before February 2025.
And so, they've already sweeped him presumably, but they're why
are they looking again, right? Why are they looking through his
statements again to find something that's not protected by the
First Amendment? And the reason is because they're targeting
them and he was probably picked out specific like Hassan is famous.
He's one of the he's the biggest political streamer. I wouldn't
be surprised if they drew a list with his name on it specifically.
I know one of the reasons that you can get denied global entry
is for contact with like criminals and terrorists. Do you think
that it is a valid like let's say they didn't know about like
the Houthi interview and the contact he had with that uh person.
Do you think it's valid to revoke Global Entry based off of his
connection there or do you Okay, this would be a good question.
I think it's way too tenuous. I don't think it amounts to material
support. I think that would justify like I don't know any No,
sorry. It I think it says it doesn't say that you provide material
support. I think it just means I think it just says contact like
you have contact with these individuals. No, I'm I'm referencing
first amendment standards. So there's a first amendment standard
of material support and abs. So I know that, but I'm saying for
the global entry revocation reasons. I think it says that if
you have Okay. Why would Pisco care about that? Are you arguing
that the Global Entry rules supersede the first amendment? I
don't think so. I think the first amendment is kind of important.
Tell you the truth individuals. Yeah. So like I don't really
care about the So I understand. Understood. Right. like the global
entry if you have contact with criminal individuals perhaps that's
a viewpoint neutral way of of doing this kind of thing. But um
you're saying the underlying reasoning is like it wouldn't be
people discrimination necessarily to to disfavor individuals
who have contacts with crim with provable criminals, right? People
who have been are known to the to be criminals. But for the for
a kind of like interview, even if it was a kind of glazing interview,
no, I think that that's that crosses a line threshold. And I
also don't think that the rationale is because they're actually
concerned that he's interacting with these people. It's because
they want to chill speech. And I don't know why we're making
all these apologies and excuses for the Trump administration.
Like they're actually concerned of Assan. What they're concerned
about is I'm not trying to apologize for what what's going on
here, right? You agree, right? The most likely scenario is that
there was viewpoint discrimination. Correct. I think I think
we can separate these two things out. The global entry I think
it's much more likely that viewpoint discriminate. You're saying
that the denial is not a violation of the first amendment. So
I guess this always comes down to and I'm not sure what the the
rule is on this, right? Um, if I were to take something that
maps onto a discriminated class, if I were to take if I were
to take somebody saying ninja the the soft a okay if I if I was
to take that word and say, "Hey, saying this word saying this
word actually
um yeah, we just we discriminate against that, right? Sorry,
we don't discriminate. We um we revoke your global entry for
that. You say this word, you're out. You're out. You're out.
Okay, we say that. Now, the people who say that word, that's
going to map onto a group pretty specifically in a pretty like
uh aggressive way. No, you baked in the premise that No, I'm
trying to think of the example here, right? So, we could say,
oh, well, you know, technically him associating with the Houthi,
that's like not something somebody with of a certain viewpoint
would do, right? That's just like it's just associating with
a Houthie. But I'm saying if you were to take a behavior that
would be associated to a protected class, if you were to take
some behavior or something you'd say, you were to if you were
to take that and say that that's what we actually suspend your
global entry pass for, that wouldn't be really be a valid way
to do it, right? The issue there isn't the securitybased threat
interpretation. This is a particular class of people that is
protected. Okay, I could come up with one. I could easily come
up with one and I think this is one. That's my broad argument
here is I think that probably somebody who would be willing to
interview this guy is somebody who has a certain viewpoint and
I think basically making that interview uh tan amount to something
that would get your taken away is viewpoint discrimination. That's
that's what I assume. What about associating with January 6th?
That's tough. That's a tough one. Um I'd have to think about
that one. Black Irish. I'd have to think about that one. It's
not comparative. It's not comparative. Use racial crime stat
crime stats disingenuously.
Uh, but then that would be that wouldn't be so that would be
something that does map onto the the group, I guess. I don't
know. I I haven't thought through a lot of this. We're just we're
just winging it here. Okay. I just wanted to see what the arguments
were around this so I could start thinking about it. I'm asking
you your overall take. So, more likely than not, that is to say,
uh, 50.001%
uh, do you believe that it it was more likely than not view discrimination
the revocation of global entry? I would say 70% yes. Okay. But,
okay. The other thing is I want to separate out the global entry
revocation from the interview which was the thing that started
this because I think there's a much stronger case for revoking
global entry based off viewpoint discrimination than there is
for this stop and detainment because it seemed like initially
they didn't even know who son was until they checked him afterwards
and they got about his job. Well, but here but now now now the
reason we started with this is now that we're armed with this
knowledge that we think more likely than not and I agree with
you that the revocation is due to viewpoint discrimination that's
going to affect our prior on whether or not the questioning has
to do with viewpoint discrimination. So if the revocation is
itself based on viewpoint discrimination that you agree all else
equal increases our prior the questioning is based on viewpoint
discrimination. It increases our priors on on on the the interview
being based on uh viewpoint discrimination.
But but there's there's a couple things. Okay. one again if he's
starting out by asking him about you know why he's in Chicago
and then Hassan offers what he's doing in Chicago has to do with
journalism and then continues to offer and he himself expresses
I'm trying to push this so he offers all this information about
his job and the interviewer generally is going to like like you
know when I've gone through checkpoints or whatever they're like
oh what are you doing here and then they ask me questions along
those lines I feel like everybody goes through this it doesn't
seem like these were pointed questions initially if it started
off by if it started off by them saying like Trump what do you
think about the war come on dude You don't believe this. They're
going to start off with, "Wait, wait, wait, hold up. Do you think
it's unreasonable if I if I ask you, okay, what are you doing
in Chicago?" and you tell me you're there for a journalism, and
then I do do I not continue along those lines of questioning,
or do I do I just abandon that? So, you're being unreasonable
now based on So, I'm going to address what you just said. I think
that you can't read into the fact that they start with those
opener lines because they would start with those opener lines
no matter what. They're not going to go into it raw. You would
never expect them to go into it raw under any circumstance. Have
you ever heard Why did he phrase it like that? Why you say like
that though? Heard of interview that starts with hey did you
do the thing that we care about? Nothing. So how can we read
into these kind of open isn't this like kind of unfalsifiable
then? Because if they weren't doing this then they would start
with the same questioning. If they were doing this they would
start. No. What I'm saying is you can't read that much into the
opening questions to get to like well the fact that they didn't
start with do you support Trump? We can read into that. I'm just
telling you it's not very that that those decision of when to
what to start with in terms of like starting with his career
and what he's doing there that you can't read into that some
non-intent and that they're just like I don't know socially they're
trying to get a feel for him because then you have to have answer
why are they asking these questions right you have to answer
that well I think I I mean there like like here's here's here's
my thought process okay if Assan goes up there and he's like
oh I'm here for journalism and then the guy's next question was
like what do you speak about and Assan said Twitch and then Hassan
says oh what am I going to say just games if Assan had just said
games do you think they would continually pressed him until he
just got into politics and then eventually said, "I don't support
Trump." So, I I do think they would have continued to press him
because they had because what do you think their purpose was?
Cuz I I have an idea what their purpose was. And you have I don't
know what your idea is of what their purpose is. My idea for
what their purpose was is to get is anybody they interview are
going to they're looking for ways to trip them up to say something
up because that's their whole job is to find. So, you don't think
that when they were asking uh Rezling, thank you for the four
months, buddy. New new individual sub. Let's go. Thank you. Thank
you. Questions. They kind of knew what his his deal was. They
didn't have his file that they didn't know about the I'm sure
I'm sure they the revocation of his of his double entry. You
think they knew about that? That they didn't ask about it. But
but not they didn't know about it. He can't know that if they
didn't know about it. I I think Assan said himself that they
were do they got the passports and then they did like a check
on who they were. He can know what the they're doing. All right.
So So first of all, he can't know what they're doing. But no,
I'm just I'm just admitting to you that I agree that they knew
who he was when he like after after they at least after they
gave him his passport. I'm saying I'm agreeing with you, but
I'm just But like there's just there's just a couple like the
the line of questioning doesn't seem unreasonable to me. I'm
just saying No, baby. You're drawing some Okay, hold on a second
here. I'm uh guys, I'm going to end on Twitch here. Go over to
kick only for the rest of the stream. Okay, love you guys on
Twitch. Going to head over to kickon. All right, we'll see you
guys over there in just a second. Give me two
and we'll see you guys there. Okay, have a good one. Bye-bye.
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. kick only for the rest of the stream
and then I'm gonna
me. Why is this kick thing not working ever? Oh, hold on. Is
that it? That is it. Okay, there we go. There we go. On singular
streaming again. Okay, paste. We're over on kick. I'm going to
hit play on this. I'm kind of still scouting for yachtis when
we're going to get her. Okay. All right. Conclusions based on
the fact that they opened with I need to be right back. I just
scanned some water using the back. Standard question. Yeah, but
but my question is like if why are you drawing inference? Because
that is compatible and equally likely on both accounts that they
have a viewpoint discrimination purpose and they don't. So why
that's my point that's my point though if it's likely on both
accounts that they have viewpoint discrimination or they don't
then we can't just say that like oh him asking about you know
politically relevant things when his job has to do with politics
that's not a example of him pushing. So so so the when they ask
you do you support Trump right assume that they ask that do you
support Trump? Yeah. What's a possible good reason for asking
that question? Um, if like if you're a person who just wants
to like harm Trump or something like I don't think it's an unreasonable
question if you say like your job has to do with politics and
you're like what does this like this guy's coming to our country
what do they think about our country leader so as a US weird
yeah I do I think it's weird. I think it's weird. So what you're
saying is like it's for US citizens who are stopped as a routine
part of the check. You wouldn't have a problem with them asking
whether or not they support Trump or not as a policy if their
if their job has to do with political really. Yeah. I So you
think it's okay. You think it's okay for the for the government
TVB officers to be screening people and asking them questions
whether they support a particular candidate as long as their
job relates to their politics? Not not I'm saying that it's probably
a safe bet to say that to ask questions around your your political
stuff if you're doing political things because what if this person's
like a crazy person or they're dangerous. What I'm saying is
you can say that about anyone stop by CPP who has any affiliation
with the news or politics that you because why not ask them whether
or not they support the mayor of New York or ask them whether
or not they support the governor of California or ask them whether
they support any Democratic you know ex-president or something
that logic is like expansive as why are they asking about Trump
well maybe it's because they're genuinely concerned that this
guy is a security threat to the president of United States and
he might be crazy who knows or do you think do you think that's
more plausible or the that this is viewpoint discrimination and
they're trying to chill descent and chill speech which you think
is more likely I want to lean under this administration towards
viewpoint discrimination. However, okay, I think that if this
were happening on in in the way that you think it's h or you're
saying it's happening in this case, then the administration would
be hiding it and that there would be journalists and other people
on this top down order. They're not hiding it. I'm not saying
they're hiding it in other cases or in like maybe similar things,
but I'm talking about like you're saying that there's this matter
of policy within the TSA or whatever that or border control or
whatever that has that is saying this wood baby clip. Hold on
a second. Apparently Woodby's sitting in Tel Aviv right now.
Who would have thought? We can get a transcript of the interview.
No, we did not. So, they're kind of going off Hassan's word and
splitting between, oh, we believe Hassan, we don't believe Hassan.
Oh my god. Oh my god. I just saw two things shoot through the
sky there. I just saw two things. There's like a plane there.
Did you hear that? Oh my god. Fireworks. There it is. There it
is. There it is. There it is. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god.
Oh my god. Oh my god.
Oh my god. Oh my god. Fireworks. Oh my god. Is this Is this
There's more over, bro. Imagine. Hold on. Imagine. Wait. We She
didn't get the the actual strike, did she? Oh my god. For some
reason, I want to say that she might have gotten the actual strike.
Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my
god. Oh my god.
Bruh. These aren't fireworks. Get to a bomb shelter. I'm on the
wrong side. Look.
Oh my god. Get to a bomb shelter now. Stardust. True. Wow.
Wow. Wow. Fireworks. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow.
Wow. Fireworks. Wow. Wow.
I could have sworn that some streamer was the one who got like
the best look at Hold on. I thought a streamer is like the one
who got the best look at the the like big impact in Tel Aviv.
Am I crazy? Israeli Air Force reportedly struck an Iranian radar/am
site just to the west of Tran near the city of Keral Kage.
explosions and anti-air fire over the Iranian city of Isfahan
as the Israeli Air Force strikes targets in the area. Bro, do
you think we're going to see a single Israeli like fighter get
downed despite all of these massive operations? Like look at
when India when India struck into Pakistan, didn't they lose
multiple fighters? I'm pretty sure they did. And Israel is not
like getting Israel's losing nothing. Israeli air force successfully
struck the Iranian air force hangers at Meabad airport in Thran
tonight. Multiple hangers hosting Iranian MiG29s and Sue2 24s
from the 11th and 14th tactical fighter squadrons appear to be
burning. Bro, this is not going to F-14 Tomcats possibly targeted
as well. Wait, Iran. Oh, cuz Iran was uh supported by the United
States for a while, right? So F-14 Tomcats. When did the Sha
get overthrown?
Uh Iranian
1979. So these would be like 70s fighters, right? So they'd have
F-14 com uh like Tomcats from the 70s. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Cool. Fun fact. I love that fact. That's very fun. Multiple large
explosion. Dude. Dude. Iran.
Iran's going to get Yeah. Israel striking back at Iran right
now. Obviously. Leak on the Iranian air defense. Okay. This was
uh this was funny the last time. I'll look at it again. Intel
leak on Iranian air defense. Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Like crusty air force. They cannibalize parts from other F-14s.
Oh, I think I read about that. That they actually buy like decommissioned
F-14s from other places to keep those running. Pakistan has much
better modern equipped military uh compared to Iran. Where would
Pakistan buy their weapons from? Who makes like Pakistan's air
defense that it would be that much better? Israel's running the
scoreboard. Dude, where's the Somebody get me? Porter Bell, you
get the Fuentes clip on on Israel versus Iran and Israel versus
like the other actors in the region. Can we get the Can we get
the Fuentes clip on that, please? because that is just by far
the most accurate analysis of the situation. They're US allies.
Yeah, but I don't think they have US jets, do they? I need that.
Somebody get me that clip. Wood Baby knows it's real now. Hold
on. What is this? Pakistan Air Force's F-16s and J10s. Okay,
but we be we be talking about their air defense, not their air
force, right? Like I don't think I don't think we're dog fighting
our way out of this, right? Am I crazy? Let me put pants on like
Chinese Sams. This S400s.
S400. Oh, but wouldn't Iran have these? Wouldn't Iran have S400s
from Russia? Mobile surfaceto-air missile system developed in
the 1990s by Russia's M no Amas is an upgrade to S300 family
missiles. Wouldn't this actually just be what they'd have? Wrong.
Although these systems are located in Syria, they are under the
command of the Russian military, not the Syrian nor Iranian military,
making the Russian government liable if they used against another
state. 2019, some Iranian officials expressed interest in procuring
the S400 missile system to further improve its defense capabilities
along with previously purchased
Uh Russia stated at the time it was ready to sell the S400 system
to Iran if an official request was made. In November 2024, Dvoo
Shekan, deputy for operations of the IRGC Aerospource Force,
stated that Iran never requested the S400 systems and that Iran's
current capabilities were far superior to them. Additionally,
stating that Iran is actively using the S300. This is in contradiction
both to reports that from Iran's media outlets addressing its
attempts to acquire the S400 and other reports of it the disabling
of all active S300 systems belonging to Iran during Israeli air
strikes. Oh, that's another thing that I've seen talked about
is with a lot of these air strikes happening, um there's some
people who think that Israel's basically hacked all of the Russian
tech that that Iran has and they can just disable whatever they
want. like like possibly they'd be under some threat like especially
in the volume of attacks they're doing but that they just they've
like hacked all of their [__] and Iran's like totally
like in every possible way and their their air defense just doesn't
work as the Israel's going in for attacks. Uh that's okay. Okay.
List of equipment. Pakistan air force. No, Pakistan has the S400,
right? Pakistan's on here. Pakistan. Pakistan claimed it had
targeted and destroyed components of India's S400 rejected the
damage to the system. Okay. Is claimed by several outlets that
an IIAF S400 system intercepted and destroyed a PAF Awax aircraft
approximately 314 kilometers inside uh Pakistani airspace. However,
that has not been officially confirmed. Never mind. Pakistan
does not have S400s.
GG. Did Israel kill Iranian civilians? Almost certainly. Yes.
Pakistan has Chinese Sams. Oh, you said that. Be very vivic.
Sorry, you did say that. Sorry, you did say that. True. All right.
Okay. I'm I'm good without wood baby either. I'm going to start
skipping over towards the hunter thing. We'll see how Piscar
goes against Hunter here. I'm uh I'm aware of Chris Krebs who
was denied global entry because discrimination either in the
revocation or the stopper. Thanks a lot. I agree. What's up,
buddy? Can you hear me? Yeah, I can hear you. Listen to Hunter
conversation real quick and then I'm going to jump into some
other stuff after this. So, just clarify. Have you seen this
unhinged Destiny clip? He kind of walks it back jokingly though.
I don't know what this is. What is this? Jessica has repeatedly
said he will coordinate mass emailing campaigns. Any mainstream
person you collab with in the future eventually must confront
the juice question. Um, I'll wait till this case is over. I mean,
like I said, his television was already out there, so Oh, that
he like keeps doing the thing. FBI about
they woke Oh, yeah. He made this up entirely. It's so crazy that
he just makes things up whole cloth. Mass emailing. I think I
said that probably somebody should do that. I' I've joked about
doing it this morning. We had a wonderful chat. But hey, I have
a first amendment baby. F first amendment right to call for this
guy's death. And well, I guess technically it is a first amendment
right to dox people, but I'm pretty sure that that that can fall
under some uh some actual statutes in Florida. We'll see. To
be clear, when I say his stuff is out there, I mean that like
people have seen all the the dumb that he said and been involved
in. Yeah, that's definitely that's definitely what he meant there.
The all the he's been involved with like what that anybody should
do anything violent or mean or evil or anything like that. I
would never encourage Wow. What? Wow.
What a cool guy.
What a cool guy over here. We're a peaceful type here. Okay.
The deli ban. Uh-huh. Wow. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool.
Very cool. Son got the conditional approval last year, right?
Correct. Okay. And then he got his membership card. Was it February?
He got the full approval notice in February. I don't know if
he if he ever got his card, but he definitely got that approval
notice in February. Okay. And then it was the revocation that
happened on the was it the 5th of March? Something like that.
Okay. If is it conceivable to you that something between those
events could happen that would justify the CBP revoking the membership
card? When you say conceivable, do you mean Hold on one second.
My uh my headphones are clicking really badly. Need to reset
these super
logically possible or what do you mean by that? Um
like is there something that would sway you more than 50% that
it's justified that he would have his uh membership card revoked?
So I'm asking when you say is there something that could do you
mean is it there logically possible that something that could
sway me? The answer is yes. Okay. You didn't expect him to bite
this. You didn't expect him to say wait Hunter you should have
absolutely expected this. Did he bite the bullet that like bite
the bullet that if there was new evidence that showed it was
clearly not the thing he said. Then he would have to accept it.
Yeah. I mean Pisc was not a [__] Of course he's going
to say yes. No it's coming. Okay. We'll see. Okay. Do you think
that Okay. Hey, did you see the Mike Johnson stuff around Gavin
Newsome where he I think he was questioned about Gavin Newsome
and he said they should be like tart and feathered or something
like that. Um I'm not sure about that statement. I don't recall
hearing anything about it. Okay. Assuming that's true, would
you see that as being like a a threat or like an invocation of
like a threat or like insinuation or anything like that? He should
be that someone should be tared and feathered. Yeah. Not necessarily
like illegal first amendment or anything.
Depends on the context. So I can I whether or not it's protected
or whether or not I think it's a threat depends on the context.
Okay. Um, if you were to take it to like its most extreme version
where it's saying that somebody is somebody wants somebody else
to be tart and feathered and it is like he means it in like the
literal sense of like this dude should basically be like do you
think that would be an instance in which it would be justified
for CBP to revoke somebody's membership card? No. Wait, wait.
Is Pisco Hold on. Is Pisco arguing right here that he's like
actually if you threaten to kill somebody if you said somebody
needs to be killed, you don't think CBP should be able to revoke
this? Is that what he's Is that the bullet he's biting? because
that seems a little crazy. You don't think it would be No, I
think I take it to be protected speech whether to to think that
someone should be dead or that they deserve to die and so I would
not. He is saying okay actually he went even further and made
it very clear. Well, I appreciate that. That's very nice. I was
just like, well, are you saying that they should just be able
to say this guy should die? Yeah, absolutely. You should be able
to say this guy should die. Okay, cool. Be in favor of discriminating
on the basis of that viewpoint. Now, to be clear, that would
not mean that you're free from any consequences should that happen.
I I think that's Hold on, hold on, hold on. He's arguing that
that would still be protected speech if you were saying it in
a political context, right? As in like you couldn't be jailed
for that, but I don't think that protects you from like civil
action or possible anything like that, right? Like it's I don't
think he'd say that, okay, you could just do that or that it's
morally good, right? He's saying he's not saying it's morally
good. He is saying that yeah the government shouldn't be able
to harm you for that. Okay. So you think let me let me just clarify
to make sure I'm understanding the appearance of a threat you
don't think is justified enough for the revocation. Wait hold
on soap box. He clarified he went further and said if they mean
which he should have said okay what if they call for the person's
death right cuz he said what if they mean it literally as in
like getting that person killed or something. Right. What you
were describing Iran seems like they are not a real threat. Wait,
are you talking to Was that a reply to somebody else? I would
say they're not a real threat. Uh, they're not a threat to erase
Israel as they are right now. They are a real threat to do harm
to somebody around them. Obviously, they've perpetuated a lot
of harm in the region. They're not like not a threat. I'm saying
that if it if there is a real direct conflict, Israel will absolutely
decimate Iran in a way Iran won't recover from and or or won't
recover from from a for a long time militarily,
right? And it won't be close. Like it will just be it'll be like
99 to1. Like I think Iran's done Iran went as hard as they possibly
could here, right? That's not protected by f the first amendment.
Hold on. Did something change? because he's saying I wish this
person were dead is basically something that should h should
be protected, right? I don't think it's I think somebody should
kill this guy. It's like I wish this guy was dead. I think that's
he's trying to make the difference there. Let me let me just
clarify to make sure I'm understanding. The appearance of a threat
you don't think is justified enough for the revocation.
Uh you can you can find some edge cases where
where it's unclear whether it's a a true threat or where it doesn't
appear to be just like punishing. I don't think Israel and Iran
can directly engage in military conflicts. They both don't have
expeditionary milit militaries. Even if Israel had an expeditionary
military, they would have to go and like basically occupy Syria
and Iraq to get towards Iran and actually be able to establish
bases to be able to invade Iran, right? Like they don't have
a way into Iran.
That's the problem for Israel. Iran and Iran kind of gets saved
by this too. That's why Iran doesn't have like a lot of like
I don't know I like a traditional military in a lot of ways,
right? They do a lot of like strikes, a lot of ballistic missiles.
I don't even know if they have an air force. Like, it's hard
for Israel to actually use their fighters to strike Iran because
of refueling issues. Like, if Iraq, if Saddam were still in power
in Iraq and wanted to with Israel, let's say, let's say that
we go back, I don't even know how to run the hypothetical. If
Iraq had like a stable uh a stable regime and roughly close to
what they had for air defense before, it would actually be a
risk to fly over Iraq and try to do refueling to go and strike
Iran, right? Like I think it's actually a military like a major
issue for them. They would use US military bases as staging points.
I guess sure there are US military bases in Iraq, right? Maybe
I think like it's a major issue for them trying to refuel right
now. Okay. Yeah. So they're not going to invade each other. But
I'm saying that like basically Iran has set themselves up to
have like air defense and stuff and none of it will actually
work against what Israel has and Israel can just keep striking
their production facilities over and over again. And Israel could
start trying to [__] their economy too. I don't think
Israel has targeted any like fuel refining areas yet, right?
Fuel refining or like um like oil reservoirs. I don't think they've
they've hit anything like that. They could start trying to hit
Iran's economy too, but I think because they don't want to disrupt
the glo like once you start disrupting the global economy and
the flow of oil. Yeah. you'll be in trouble. So, I think they've
stuck away from that. But I think there's there's some somewhere
on the east coast in the Gulf of Oman, there's like major refineries
or some like kind of processing plants that Iran uses to push
oil out into the the the rest of the world. And if they hit those
things, I think I think things get right, don't they get like
super immediately? This going to raise gas prices? I thought
gas prices were already going up. Yeah, Iran being a military
conflict will raise gas prices almost certainly, speculatively
if nothing else.
in them based a class of speaker based on the viewpoint. So perhaps
you know there are some cases in which you know it's a close
call um and I could see a justified security rationale but whatever
that nebula zone is we're not there. Okay. Um do you remember
the thing that
Rick Scott by chance? So you cut out. Yeah. Do you remember the
uh the tweet that Hassan had made about Rick Scott? Um something
to Oh he talked about this on stream as well. Just so you know
Hunter the effect of I don't know. I don't remember. It's it
was like insinuation that if anyone deserve to die or something
like that. Yeah. He said if Mike Johnson cares about Medicare
fraud since he wants to cut $800 million from Medicaid Medicare,
he'd call for max punishment for current uh
Florida D senator/former Governor Rick Scott who has done the
most Medicare fraud in US history. Like yeah, not not on the
basis of it being is perceived or is Oh man, Hunter, you could
have had a good point here if you'd done the uh if you'd done
if you'd done the gun. If you've done the the Shinszo AB assassination
weapon in Tom Cotton, I think it's I think it's way better more
likely than not to be a insinuation that this person should be
not literally necessarily, but it could be interpreted. Yeah,
that's speech. It's not even close. Not even close. Yeah, you
should not at all. And you would agree, wouldn't you, that if
we did that if for example the government said you can't get
social security because you said that, you would be against that,
right? punch my hand
if they were revoking stuff that you're opted into from my understanding
that like social security is something that everybody's inherently
maybe not inherently but everybody's like afforded social security
but I think there's a distinction here with the CBP global entry
pass where you opt into it and it's optional so I asked you a
question if someone denied social security benefits on the basis
of that message would you say would you say that's wrong
yes why would it be wrong
sorry can you repeat Why? Why would it be wrong? Uh because you're
taking somebody's protected speech to
uh revoke something that they're entitled to. Yo, vert dummy.
Thank for the two gifted. Let's go. Thanks. Thanks. Thank you.
Thank you. Okay. So, if the government, you think they're entitled
to the Global Entry pass? No. No. No. No. But so, if under that
logic, if do you think that they can condition Global Entry on
approval for Trump? I don't know why Pisces about social security
when Yeah. I'd say government's taking money from you to pay
into social security all your life. I don't I feel like that
is uh like literally probably your right to get that refunded
in a way you expect, right? Yeah. So I don't know why he would
ask that. That seems kind of rough. Um
I don't think so. No. Wait, but you're not Wait, but you're not
entitled to it. You're not entitled to it, right? So why? So
of course you're going to do it because you're not entitled to
it. Sure. But my my main point here is why doesn't that follow?
Wait, why doesn't that follow? So I'm I'm asking I want I want
to connect this first real quick. I want to connect this real
because you said that it's it's weird that the revocation happened
so soon after Trump's inauguration. Correct. Is that what you
were saying earlier? I'm not saying that it's so weird that it
happened so soon after his inauguration. I'm saying that so soon
after the time it was granted. Okay. Um do you think it's more
likely that it was due to Trump's election or him being elected
rather than the case of the Rick Scott incident happening 2 days
prior to the revocation of the CBP pass? I'm not sure. I think
it's more like
regardless of Oh, this is you got to get into like basically
what you think percentages are here. I think you guys get to
that. You're saying both would be unacceptable. Both would be
unacceptable. I just want to clear about that. So, it does it
doesn't matter if it's the viewpoint of discrimination on Rick
Scott. I think that that's less likely given what he was asked
at the border visi all that stuff. And given everything else
happened in Israel, I think that points much into the favor of
like that this is having to do with his opinions on Israel, political
opinions. But if it had to do with his political opinion on RC
Rick Scott, it wouldn't help you. Still discrimination. So, we're
going to go back to my questions, which is why would it be the
case that why is Pisco going so fast suddenly? What the [__]
Approval for Trump in the moment, too, since I don't debate.
It's hard to identify in the moment. And then the way Yeah, sure,
sure, sure, sure. Um, yeah, I can see what you mean. It is very
hard in the moment to actually argue these things. It's so much
easier from chat to argue these things. This goes argument essentialized.
1A protects against discrimination. CBP is a government arm and
therefore 1A included in 1A interpretation.
Well, when enforcing their policies, right? So, you can have
a policy that you can't do something, but like if your if your
policy is, well, this like speech would make you a concern, like
a security concern for us, they should take the 1A protections
on speech and apply them. Like, is that protected speech? Is
that a is that an actual class of protected speech? Yes.